Washington Post national correspondent
Philip bump joins us now Philip good
morning morning any indication any
insight right now as to when the
articles of impeachment gets sent over
could they be held indefinitely
yeah I'm making me held as long as as
long as the house wants to do it I mean
I think we're really seeing here's sort
of a power struggle the Democrats have
controlled this impeachment process for
months they're very eager to try and
help set the terms and conditions under
which the Senate trial moves forward and
I think they're also happy to have this
sort of atmosphere of questions about
how fair the Senate trial will be
because that will help color the actual
result of what on this issue of
witnesses I distinctly remember the
impeachment of another president and
Mitch McConnell was leading the chorus
on we have to have them so how are you
able to stand behind this this this sort
of flood of people on the Republican
side saying no witnesses moving forward
speedily and will there be I mean is
there any quick recourse for Democrats
there's not a lot I mean it all it takes
is a majority vote in the Senate in
order to set the rules for what happens
and of course Republicans have a
majority there I mean I think we should
be there's a lot of talk about precedent
the president is only one right as you
said they've been pretty tune of
President Clinton in 1998-1999 this
question of witnesses is interesting
because the Republicans don't want to
necessarily open the floodgates for four
witnesses because I have a lot of
moderates and the moderates arkin he'll
go along with this idea of bringing in
all sorts of random people who can
perhaps impunity impeachment process in
Mitch McConnell also doesn't want to
open the doors for them bringing in
witnesses that will actually attack
president Trump so he may just say no
witnesses at all in order to avoid that
you mentioned some of the positive I
guess for the Democrats right now
holding on to these articles of
impeachment but overall Democrats also
for the president what's the danger
going forward if they stay there in the
house and and don't go forward well I
think of it I haven't seen a lot of
evidence so far the Republicans are
really that worried about it the
Republicans don't like the impeachment I
don't think they're necessarily eager to
spend a lot of time again airing the
president's dirty laundry and all the
Ukraine things the president himself is
very eager to have this in and take the
vote and say oh no I've been acquitted
he wants to be able to stand at a rally
and be able to say that so I'm sure he's
putting some pressure on them but I'm
not sure how strong this is actually for
Levin is it there's also though what
people are so annoyed by politics by is
this idea of a stalemate right now and
neither side trying
work together I mean I think to some
extent but I mean the our our politics
right now are so polarized anyway that
all the Democrats are gonna have one
feeling all their bookings gonna have
another feeling we've seen that over the
course of the impeachment all right so
the demo last democratic debate took
place on Thursday pepo de jedge came
under fire like he hasn't before the
next debate there were seven candidates
on stage at this one next democratic
debate is in January how many on stage
then what happens then it's a good
question they've again escalated the
requirements for getting on stage it's
remains to be seen I think of four or
five have already qualified I think one
of the things that candidates have seen
is that there hasn't been a lot of
change after these debates I think one
of the reasons people judge came under
fire is because they've seen that his
poll numbers go up and down so maybe
with people can peel away some of his
voters but I think people right now are
really starting to transition into okay
once the primaries and caucuses actually
start that's when there's gonna be a big
shake-up and January may end up being
just sort of a placeholder until we
actually start voting boom thank you
have a good holiday thank you
you